et ben non et bien non matic de s'y
retrouver
une première à la maison difficile pour
mathilde de gros la championne d'europe
de kerhinet éliminé de sa discipline
phare elle échoue en demi finale de
l'épreuve après une quatrième place au
sprint
pour l'instant je suis votre bilan je
vais plutôt prendre les points positifs
regardez toutes les erreurs tactiques
que j'ai fait pour pouvoir aller mettre
en oeuvre enfin voilà justement ne pas
faire les mêmes erreurs dans une semaine
à toronto
les pistards français termine sept
manches avec trois médailles l'argent
pour le trio baugé viger d'almeida en
vitesse par équipes et le bronze pour
adrien garrel au scratch et benjamin
thomas sur l'omnium
on va retenir le positif voilà le pour
petit personnel la troisième place sur
l'omnium ya eu des grandes sensations
voilà c
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
j'avais pas vibrer avec le public et ça
a été vraiment un grand moment et on
avait ça fait du bien d'avoir des
compétitions en france chez nous
quelques quelques regrets on était à
domicile on espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
meilleurs résultats on a tenté
du genre de nos sportifs sont sortis
assez rapidement
dans les manches de qualification donc
quelques regrets là on est rentré dans
la sélection olympique
qui va nous emmener à tokyo il ya 16
manches la première c'était le
championnat d'europe là c'est la
deuxième et on se qualifie sur les a
préparés que prochaine échéance pour le
clan français en fin de semaine la
deuxième manche de coupe du monde se
tient du 26 au 28 octobre
hamilton au canada
[Applaudissements]